good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight believe it or not in
1980 which wasn't that long ago
venezuela was the richest country in
latin america it had the highest wages
it had the best health care and
education it also had by the standards
of the region anyway a famously stable
democracy
then came an energy crisis and venezuela
wound up with inflation at times it
reached a hundred percent a year
inflation makes people poor so in a very
short time the poverty rate in venezuela
doubled by 1995 66 percent of all
venezuelans were impoverished
getting poorer tends to make voters
radical so inevitably venezuela got
radical politics you know what happened
next venezuela is now raided one of the
most miserable places on planet earth
a few years ago citizens in caracas were
reduced to eating zoo animals there was
no food and for that matter there was no
electricity
so in just half a lifetime an advanced
society had reverted to the stone age
the united states is not in danger of
becoming venezuela next week but we are
moving closer to it inflation is a big
part of the reason
of all the economic crises a country can
face inflation is the most dangerous
inflation doesn't just make people poor
it totally destroys their confidence in
their leaders the authorities who issued
the now worthless currency they're using
for toilet paper
inflation is not an act of god like a
drought or hurricane it's an act of
negligence like drunk driving it is
proof that the people in charge are
reckless and stupid that's why inflation
tends to topple governments once you get
inflation there's no pretending you've
done a good job you have not done a good
job and everybody knows it
so you can see why the byte
administration is very worried about
this joe biden has historically low
approval ratings voters say inflation is
their top concern those two facts are
directly related so biden's most
pressing task right now is reassuring
americans that he understands their
suffering under inflation and under a
rapidly worsening economy and he's got a
plan to fix it
if he can't convince americans of that
it may be a long time before we have
another democratic president
thankfully joe biden has a plan or at
least a new publicist a silver-tongued
wordsmith policy guru called karine
jean-pierre
it is karine jean-pierre's job to take
this message of economic hope to the
american people and save the biden
administration she started monday here
were her first words from the podium
i am obviously acutely aware
that my presence at this podium
represents a few firsts
i am a black gay immigrant woman
the first of all three of those to hold
this position
so that was a little confusing it wasn't
actually about america it was about her
but still
we learned that korean jean-pierre is a
black lesbian the first ever in history
she reminded us to hold this particular
job
listen carefully
that's shattering you here in the
background it's a thousand glass
ceilings cracking simultaneously into
millions of tiny pieces and then being
swept with the custodians of tomorrow
into the trash bin of bigotry and hate
soon they'll be trucked to a landfill
and buried it's a new day america
how do you feel
you still can't afford to have your
refrigerator fixed or go to the dentist
on the other hand karine jean-pierre has
good news for you about herself
karine jean-pierre has just reached a
highly significant personal goal and
understandably she is brimming with
self-esteem congratulations karine
jean-pierre
your promotion is america's promotion
hope it feels good you're going to want
to hold on to that sensation when you're
now experiencing and treasure it in the
days ahead like a hand warmer as america
becomes poorer than you ever imagined
possible and it is
as of tonight parents across the country
can't find baby formula oh no big deal
well it is actually a big deal because
as a result of that several children
have just been hospitalized in the state
of tennessee
fertilizer prices meanwhile have hit
record highs that will mean food
shortages around the world famine in
some places starvation it'll mean
shortages here
food inflation bloomberg reports will
quote leave no household unscathed
and then gas prices also just hit an
all-time high they're not going down
mike jennings the ceo at a major refiner
says gas prices will stay high for this
foreseeable future quote i don't see any
signs of it ending soon or well
and that's true of inflation across
every major sector of this economy axios
reporting tonight that quote inflation
is pushing prices higher and higher and
some of those costs may never come back
down to the levels americans were
accustomed to before the pandemic
more than half the ceos in this country
publicly predict that recession is
imminent that's what they're saying in
public imagine what they're saying in
private morgan stanley says there's a 27
chance we get a recession in the next 12
months that's up from 5 just two months
ago so that's scary but the scariest
fact of all we appear to be running out
of energy
congress never passed the green new deal
but we somehow got it anyway and hear
the results
according to wall street journal quote
from california to texas to indiana
electric grid operators are warning that
power generating capacity is struggling
to keep up with demand
that gap could lead to rolling blackouts
during heat waves or other peak periods
as soon as this year in other words turn
on your air conditioning in august and
it won't work another will your lights
the mid continent independent system
operator which oversees the energy grid
in the midwest says it's preparing to
quote take emergency measures in advance
of capacity issues this summer in other
words no more electricity
the north american electric reliability
corporation which oversees energy output
in the country released an assessment
this year saying the entire western u.s
is quote
at risk of energy emergencies due to the
limited supply of electricity available
for transfer
so this has never happened it's
happening now why why is this happening
well according to the wall street
journal quote the challenge is that wind
and solar farms which are among the
cheapest forms of power generation don't
produce electricity at all times and
need large batteries to store their
output for later use
now that's only a big problem
it turns out to be an insurmountable
problem given that nearly half of new
electricity generation capacity in the
u.s last year 42 percent was from
land-based wind farms
put a lot of eggs in the wind basket and
some states like california have pledged
to use 100 quote renewable energy by
2020 45.
so
maybe we will have scientific innovation
by 2045 that make that possible if we
don't california will have even less
power than it does now
you didn't think growing up in this
country there would come a time when
they couldn't keep the lights on now
that time is here
that's shocking
but if you're upset about it we'd like
you to pause and return your attention
to the fact and we're going to say this
slowly so it can sink in
our new white house press secretary is a
black lesbian
hooray
the white house press corps was duly
impressed tamed in fact which is the
point of telling them that
but our peter ducey did have one
question what is the bite administration
doing about our collapsing economy and
how exactly is the plan to increase
taxes on american citizens going to help
them pay for things
here's how karine jean-pierre responded
how does raising taxes on corporations
reduce inflation
um
so
are you talking about a specific tweet
he tweeted you want to bring down
inflation let's make sure the wealthiest
corporations pay their fair share
look you know we have talked about um we
have talked about this this past year
about
making sure that the wealthiest among us
are paying their fair share but how does
raising taxes on corporations lower the
cost of gas the cost of a used car the
cost of food for everyday americans so
look i think we encourage those who have
done very well right especially those
who care about climate change
to support a fair attack tax code that
doesn't change that doesn't charge
manufacturers workers cops builders a
higher percentage of their earnings that
the most fortunate people in our nation
and not let this that stand in the way
of reducing energy costs and fighting
this existential problem if you think
about that as an example
now you wouldn't have thought it was
possible to take talking points that
stupid that barely literate that
childish
and make them even dumber
and yeah that's exactly what she did
are you still not convinced that joe
biden knows how to handle inflation
did that
rattle your confidence rather than
bolster it then honestly there's nothing
we can do for you at this point you're
beyond reach in fact you know what you
are and you may have seen this coming
you're a racist
that's what we call people who continue
to ask complicated long questions about
joe biden's economic program they're
racists and getting rid of them is
america's greatest problem here's msnbc
to remind you
mitch mcconnell won't come close to
delivering the condemnation of white
supremacy that joe biden did today
because what because because they make a
part of the republican coalition i mean
what is the explanation for why not this
is always what the right does to appease
the white supremacist movement by saying
hey free speech don't touch speech
extremism and white nationalism which is
not only on the rise in the far dark
corners on the internet
but the rhetoric in a you know tamer
version an attenuated version i say
is now pretty
mainstream in the republican
party did you hear that from the comb
over guy
free speech is white supremacy says
chuck todd
it's white supremacy free speech talking
out of turn
reading your own script rather than the
one that chuck todd provides you is
white supremacy
that means if you're upset about food
shortages or blackouts you're a racist
racist racist racist there you are
complaining again about the precipitous
decline in your standard of living
that's always the first sign of a racist
or you don't like crime you don't like
litter you like inflation you're against
public urination in new york city you
know what you are you're a bigot pal
stop complaining
you and your free speech
gail king of cbs is a journalist a
talented and highly awarded broadcast
journalist so she knows exactly how
racist you are you're so racist that
gayle king's family members won't even
go outside anymore watch this
i'm so afraid i have a nephew who lives
in the midwest 20-something black man
who walks his dog who said i was never
afraid to walk my dog now i'm in the
midwest just walking around minding my
own business thinking this this could
happen at any time
yeah white supremacists just come out
and
kill him with the first amendment that's
what happens when you walk your dog in
this country that's how bad it is racism
against gayle king's family may be the
single biggest problem america faces
right now in fact it is
the problem is definitely not that we're
running out of energy to power
civilization that's not a big deal at
all and that's why you probably didn't
read about the fact that the interior
department just announced it is closing
millions of acres to domestic energy
production sorry gone can't have the
energy there to exist but you can't have
it you know we can do that buy it from
venezuela yes we can
20 minutes ago they told you venezuela
was a criminal regime
you know venezuela is going to provide
the oil not us we can't that's immoral
because climate change existential but
venezuela can
in the united states the bite
administration is doing everything it
can to allow the united states to buy
venezuelan oil directly
what does that add up to
don't think about that thinking about it
is racist it's like the first amendment
it's white supremacy and if you don't
believe it kareem jean-pierre
is here to remind you
donald trump is running a racist
campaign the grand wizard of the birther
movement which birtherism is inherently
racist by the way he's a racist and a
bigot which we already knew
walks like a racist talks like a racist
acts like a racist it is a racist and we
saw these awful voter suppression laws
which is really racism across the
country and we have a racist president
in the white house who
really pushes his racism like a peacock
because i'll say this we knew donald
trump was a racist i wanted to ask you
just change the topic for just a quick
second about donald trump's racist
tweets systemic racism and how that has
affected our country donald trump is the
most outwardly racist president that we
have seen in generations this country uh
needs to start talking about uprooting
institutional racism fox news was racist
before coronavirus they are racist
during the coronavirus fox news will be
racist after the coronavirus
you know we need to talk about korea's
jump here
just told you what you don't have a
conversation about and by conversation
we mean you shut up i talk
when you have a conversation about how
racist you are which is very racist so
if you can't keep the lights on or go to
the dentist or if you're one of the very
few people maybe three in the country
has noticed that honey prices have
doubled since december why is that
happening
shut up racist subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight